I like trying to figure out how do I
make $2,000 a month 2,000 a month only
2,000 per client if you could make 2,000
a month per client or you have you know
basically $8,000 coming in every month
you basically have a six figure business
so then it becomes okay what do I sell
for 2,000 a month this is what I did
with Jeremy I did it with Zach I did it
with Drew I did it like this is my model
when I invest in entrepreneurs like
YouTube Consulting we've done three
businesses Now podcast building is
another business on became six seven
figure businesses is the starting point
is at least $2,000 a month and that gets
you two calls per month I'm telling them
like I want you at the $500 an hour plus
range
okay all right so here with Jane is part
of our Mastermind and as part of that we
do a oneon-one so welcome what's on your
mind how can I help thank you I have
this uh Chinese and English Channel and
I was Oban doctor in China and I took
nursing and for the past five years I've
been really really working on you know
preparing myself to become a
psychiatrist in Canada because mental
health and holistic care is very
important right and I came from China
and there's only 1.6 billion people
right and a lot of needs there in mental
health and holistic health so I was just
wondering um with the two channel
Chinese and English you're really good
at you know YouTube and channel building
brand making and all that so I just
wondering uh do you have any suggestion
because I have so many trainings you
know functional medicine functional
Psychiatry uh Dr David Burns team
therapy um and also Dr Daniel Aman brain
coach um and you know trauma therapy
that's one of the big with Judy crine
which is one of the best trauma
therapist in the states so many
directions that I can go right and also
I hire to a group of Chinese business
consultant uh Aina and Chelsea uh so
they're helping me with the Chinese
marketing and products and business
model and top- down design but from your
Canadian perspective or North American
perspective uh what's your suggestion or
you know what's your uh steps yeah for
me to do so where do you see
the market for making money like are you
going to make money faster with the
English Market or the Chinese market
that's a good question so um there two
International Organization right now
with the trauma therapy they're very
eager to work with me and they're all
like English like one is Canadian the
other one is American right so I really
want people to have this education in
complex trauma therapy and Tim Fletcher
is the organization that they help
people over 112 countries and they have
a lift program for the trauma therapy
and also the other one is the
International Trauma Recovery
Association so they have very good
program to train people to become the
trauma recovery specialist and the coach
um so the Chinese consultant kind of
help me with the Chinese products but at
the same time I have a full-time job
with the government I'm taking care of
my dad who has Alzheimer's so I don't
want to take on too much at the same
time I do want to help the
English-speaking organization to promote
in Chinese population at the same time
you know I want to make it available for
Chinese population in Chinese too I
would say both because the knes is so
great right so here's always the
challenge as the beginning it's like you
have a giant mission right it's huge
right mental health right in English and
Chinese right therapy complex trauma
yeah but sure trauma therapy in English
and Chinese it's it's giant right giant
so there's so many things that you could
do right what most people get wrong is
just the sequence so like the steps yeah
I want the sequence in what order to do
it in so ultimately the goal is to do
everything but the path to be able to do
everything is to do one thing yes to
start Stay Focus because if you try to
do
everything nothing happens it's like all
of these little tiny things you do a
little in Chinese and a little in
English and you still have you care for
your father and you still have your job
all those other spread and then like
nothing ends up happening little bits of
all these things so ultimately to
accomplish your mission you're going to
need to be able to do this full-time and
then you're going to need to have a team
so it's not as you doing everything
right yeah at the beginning it's you
part-time because you're doing other
stuff right great so in our part-time
hours how do we get the most out of the
few hours that you have every day to
work on this to generate enough money
that you can then leave the job to then
generate more money so you can hire team
to then help you do the big thing right
right so we want to do everything I love
it you know it's great yes thank you and
what's the market to go after that will
pay you fastest inside your mission not
just like go get another job but inside
of what you want to do is it English
Market is it Chinese market is it
selling a specific course or program or
training or coaching what's the thing
that can generate the fastest Revenue
inside your mission so you can leave
your job do this full time so I would
say probably start with the English
Market because there are so many like in
my circle connection the networking
there's so many Chinese they're like top
professional right like since last year
I took this course uh Workshop was Eno
Lee who used to be the charge person for
Bill Gates charity fund right so there
are like 300 people that they're like
top Professionals in the states and in
China right so I form a 200 people's
group and we do this charity talk each
month with mental health and holistic
health so I would say start with the
English program Tim Fletcher and also
the uh car coaching uh with the
International Trauma Recovery
Association they all have great English
program which is already kind of
existing and working really well so
start this with the Chinese population
and then I started to build my Chinese
curriculum in Chinese with these two
organizations okay okay so you know to
leave your job you have to make a
certain amount of money every month and
have it be consistent right to replace
it exactly and and pl and be consistent
so that it's not like one good month and
then yeah you have your time that you
can sell coaching one-on-one and helping
people and then you have your programs
that you can sell yeah is there anything
else besides one-on-one in programs that
you sell so even the yeah even the
oneon-one there is this discovery kind
of 30 minutes okay but it's still
one-onone time right right or programs
right right is is there anything else
that you're selling or uh that's yeah
like the community the membership right
like that's like three to start okay but
the membership is part of the program or
no yeah if I buy your program I'm part
of the membership yeah so uh it can be
because with the high-end oneon-one
coaching that can include the courses
too right and the membership okay so you
have your you have your bulk which is
membership and courses and programs and
then you have your one-on-one high-end
clients yeah and also there's group
coaching options too right with the
courses your your fastest way is the uh
the high-end one-on ones okay because
they'll pay yeah it makes sense yeah at
the beginning that's one of the products
yeah right yeah as you scale and grow
then group coaching is next and then at
scale how much do you charge for a
one-on-one
session um so there's this Chinese money
okay right so that's about I think uh to
start because we want to T has the
market right I think it's
only I want to say
maybe
um 3,000 okay yeah in what Canadian
dollars US Dollars Chinese dollars uh I
think Chinese it's not dollars right you
yeah so uh US Dollars okay yeah great to
make up
$3,000 in in uh membership is going to
take a lot of people to sign up for the
membership right which which you can do
but it requires more scale oh I see what
you me requires more brand more content
more effort okay
ultimately the membership if you play
this out over three years you'll make
more in the membership because there's
only so many one-on ones you can do yeah
because the volume yeah your time right
you G but at the beginning if you have
10 people one-on ones versus 30 people
in your membership you'll make more from
the 10 people one sense yeah got it so
usually the start is I need to I need to
get one-on ones okay and I need to
charge a good price okay so that how
many like how many one-on ones do you
need consistently to leave the job so uh
right now like I I don't want to leave
my job yet because I really like it but
to answer your question I want to say
probably 10 okay yeah great but it's not
100 right right right so it's just 10 so
now how do we get to 10 as quickly as
possible uh started to promote well yes
but but like okay so we got our goal now
we can work the strategy to get the goal
so it's like the first goal is I need to
get the 10 oneon-one clients as quickly
as possible right from there even if you
keep your job and you have your 10 now
you have a lot more money coming in
right to hire team right you can keep
your job and then hire team to help you
do all the rest of it but if it's you by
yourself and like a little bit I help
every now and then yeah it becomes
really hard to get anything really going
yeah too much so first goal becomes how
do we get 10 one-on ones okay so not
that the other stuff is not helpful
whatever it's there but we're not going
to spend a ton of time on courses or
programs or memberships yet yeah yeah
yeah one1 stay focused focus on the one1
perfect yeah Are we more likely to get
the one ones in English or in Chinese
probably Chinese okay yeah because you
have connections to people yeah a lot of
people that they're back home or here
but with the trauma therapy and complex
trauma and the even the you know the
medical field is more like the
terminology and it's easier that to
speak the same language that we can
connect right yeah yeah I mean my wife
is Chinese right um I think the idea of
going for trauma therapy is is way more
accepted or known in English than it is
in Chinese I don't think there's like
it's still a brand new thing in in the
Chinese culture exactly you're going to
do what trauma therapy to look at you
like you're crazy yeah yeah yeah exactly
but you just need 10 yeah so you just
need the 10 right people so if the if
the path is better in Chinese than in
English to get your 10 yeah that becomes
the focus yeah so how do we get the 10
in Chinese so do we already have enough
Partnerships and connections and people
that's the two groups of Chinese
consultant that I hire um uh evina and
Chelsea their team in China okay and
have they produced anything yet or
that's just starting oh so one I sign up
in May and the other one is in August so
it has been like you know The Branding
and the picture professional shot and
story and all that yeah so it's it's
it's it's starting okay
so it's figuring out and telling them
hey guys like I want to get 10 clients
at
$3,000 to be coaching and helping and
going through my trauma therapy process
with them and you can just do it over
Zoom helping people yeah like they're
not going to come visit you in Canada
you can do it virtually right yeah okay
perfect as some may not want to and
whatever but again you just need 10 yeah
so you're having them help you you know
get some of the messaging out yeah was a
Chinese po when we go to content yeah
there's also a lot of people here who
speak Chinese right I mean I don't have
to tell you that everywhere but like
Chinese getting YouTube content in China
is hard because of all the blocking that
they do of yeah yeah yeah but there's a
giant Chinese population in North
America who have budget or their kids
are watching for their parents yeah who
have budget yeah who can pay you yeah
who would rather be in their native
tongue than in English
and probably not a lot of content even
talking about it like complex trauma
therapy I don't know how many people are
talking about that in English I'm sure
there's some people Tim
fletches you're right yeah but how much
is Tim Fletcher on YouTube making
content is he consistent is he making
yeah okay so there's one he has been
doing for the past 15 20 years great now
you get to be a second voice you know in
they're very eager to work with me to
reach out to the Chinese population it's
all in English right
so that's another angle yeah like how do
we get our 10 that could be an angle to
get your 10 to talk to Tim and say hey
Tim are there any clients that you have
or uh can we do a marketing campaign can
I make a video in Chinese that we can
send off on your Channel or to your
audience and if he takes a commission
for you know some of the leads that come
in or it's a starting point for
something much bigger but you want to go
get your 10 people oh yeah yeah I hire
another uh business coach in California
Ellen Lynn who won that billion dollar
um plague was a clickfunnel so she's
helping me with the webinar and all that
in Chinese uh in Chinese and also in
English yeah because she's in California
well what you I'm in Toronto but I'm
telling you do in Chinese like where
they are doesn't matter it's more who
are we going after right so I think if
you you could do both but if you focused
your efforts and just got your 10 yeah
that then allows you to go hire more
team to go do more things and make
things so much easier so what's our
clearest path to get to 10 so if we now
look at the the YouTube channel they
have to be separate channels you can't
have an English and Chinese channel on
the same channel they are separate
perfect yeah where do I spend more time
right now on my Chinese Channel all
right I won't understand it yeah I could
have Nina look at it and say what is she
saying but it's it probably won't hit
that many people in China right but the
Chinese population in North America will
be able to watch it and see yeah you
you're probably gonna be the only one
talking about complex trauma therapy on
YouTube in Chinese for now blue ocean
yeah and again you need 10 right we're
not trying to go eventually we're going
to go change the world yeah and be in
English and in Chinese and and Road
billions of views and everything great
right cool but the path to be able to
get there is just again the sequence
what are the steps because if you do
everything you're working with all these
Consultants and all these different
things and English and Chinese and all
it's like then again there lots of
opportunity but very little progress
right right stay focused stay focused
yeah so the first goal is get the
10 in Chinese focus on
Chinese do the webinar in Chinese for
Tim ask him about Connections in Chinese
you have your Chinese people that you
hired okay guys we need to get 10 people
that I'm going to work with oneon-one
yeah the YouTube content can be in
Chinese yeah because if you start making
regular Chinese content on YouTube for
complex trauma therapy right everybody
who is helping you can now use that
content yeah so the woman in California
can take some of those clips and put
that into the webinar and the people in
China that you hired can send some of
those videos or clip them and and use
them in their sales process that's a
good point and Tim can filter some of
his people and and send off this video
in China so like if you have content
going up people will discover you on
YouTube but your current Network can
also help share some of this stuff for
you yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good
point you don't need millions of views
on your videos yet yet like we'll get
there right totally that's the mission
yeah but we need we need the right
people seeing it who might then hire you
and you're not selling something cheap
it's not $30 an hour right you $3,000
for somebody to work with you and how
long does that last 3,000 for three
months or something or or a month or um
a year a year okay well we got to I know
e we need to how often do I meet with
you for 3,000 for a year oh weekly
weekly for a year I know e okay we we
need to raise the price right yeah yeah
yeah that's nothing yeah right what is
that a session week how long is a
session 1 hour so for for
52 hours you're charging
$3,000 right yeah what's the reasonable
price uh I probably wouldn't sell those
packages yet if you needed to for the
beginning what's your suggestion you
keep increasing you know like I would
sell one and the next one's 30% more oh
okay I would sell a 3,000 package for
three months okay but what's your ideal
kind of price range though so for this
kind of business at the beginning yeah I
like trying to figure out how do I make
$2,000 a month oh okay 2,000 a month
only 2,000 per client oh okay yeah yeah
know 2,000 a month I know is not if you
could make 2,000 a month per client or
you have you know basically $8,000
coming in every month okay you you
basically have a six figure business
right right from four clients okay so
then it becomes okay what do I sell for
2,000 a month this is what I did with
Jeremy I did it with Zach I did it with
Drew I did it like this is my model when
I invest in entrepreneurs like YouTube
Consulting we've done three businesses
now pod cast Bill another business on
right became six seven figure businesses
is the starting point is at least $2,000
a month and that gets you uh two calls
per month oh wow plus doing a little
doing work behind the scenes of you know
if it's YouTube the call is for strategy
but in between they're looking at your
channel and doing but I want to be I'm
telling them like I want you at the $500
an hour plus range oh okay us well the
problem is that like Tim Fletcher and
also care coaching they're all about
helping people right so they set their
course like kind of very economical but
we're not wor about courses 101 right
same 101 too how much is it to work with
in 101 60 bucks per hour 60 bucks an
hour I know who's doing it in Chinese no
nobody okay we got the
monopo yeah I I'd look at what is even
if you don't want to go 500 bucks an
hour we can't be at 30 bucks an hour
that's just uh it's going to take you so
long not cost effective yeah no I got
your message yeah for sure so Anna Ronco
is charging 500 per hour us yeah Anna's
Anna's a your student moving maker yeah
she great yeah and she's not
professional yeah uh yeah well not not
professionally trained I guess right in
trauma therapy that's what I'm say yeah
so yeah it's definitely doable and she
buil a brand and again you need 10
yeah so I'd be going after much higher
ticket what would you need to do for
$2,000 a month and so maybe you only
need four
people four people at 2,000 a month and
you your yeah six figure business almost
yeah yeah yeah it's six figure Canadian
is just under us right yeah yeah I
probably wouldn't do weekly but if you
wanted to do weekly for the first four
it's not the end of the world because if
you think about it if you had to do 10
people you want to do 10 people for
3,000 a year and you're going to meet
them it's 10 hours a month every month
right and you still have your job and
your father much it's a lot yeah my dad
is
247 what but now you're losing 10 hours
a month to no it's a little bit too much
well and and the work you're doing is
rough like I don't know what your
decompression after de Brave selfcare
yeah for sure right I mean yeah yeah
yeah it's you're dealing with some
intense stuff with people heavy stuff
that it's not like me I'm here doing
backtack interviews and you know like
it's fun entrepreneurship like you're
dealing with I know people's trauma like
I don't know how long you need to
recover in between but like an hour
isn't just an hour an hour might be
three hours because you need two hours
to meditate or sauna or go for a walk or
make some tea or whatever and down the
road the the the future kind of vision
or mission is to help uh healthc care
professional to do their branding right
help them to help their people yeah
again many things we can do down the
road right like there's so many things
and it's good great that excited what's
going to help us get paid you know this
year so that we can if you want to quit
your job or not but at least hire team
people to go and do yeah things for us
so yeah 2,000 a month if you want to do
a weekly call
fine uh but every two weeks I like every
two weeks better but if you want to do
weekly call no no I got your point yeah
but but 2,000 a month and now you need
four
clients who will you'll still make 8,000
a year I mean a months yeah versus
30,000 a year or 36,000 a year under
your old plan I know e yeah no that
that's much better that's sound and so
now position it with with everybody
you're dealing
with with your California woman and the
two people in China it's like here's
here's what we're selling like well
that's too expensive like well it is for
a lot of people but you only need four
people for some people it's like this is
I mean everybody has trauma yeah and a
lot of people have complex trauma you're
so wise yeah uh but it doesn't mean
everybody can afford your services and
Trauma is something that impacts
everybody no matter what income level
they have and background and like the
poorest of the poor and the richest of
the rich yeah have trauma issues yeah
yeah yeah your ultimate mission is to
help everybody but at the beginning
you're targeting the top of the top yeah
yeah yeah like if you actually help
somebody with their trauma you can
actually solve that problem that's worth
way more than $24,000 a year that's
worth it in one session people right
yeah yeah some like that's worth it the
people who are buying you know the
flying private instead of economy
they're flying to the same like private
gets to the the flight time is is longer
on a private plane than a commercial
plane right you know like this a small
plane less powerful engines now you
don't have to go through customs and
like weight in line and all that stuff
too right but you're going to the same
spot but an economy ticket is going to
be three thou $300 and yeah private
flight might be $30,000 you're going to
the same spot right right but some
people are going to pay that and for
some people it's nothing right that's
who we're targeting yeah yeah it's like
it's only $2,000 a
month yeah
okay right yeah yeah yeah got it so
those then we only need four people
right and so we're making content in
Chinese on our YouTube channel for those
people okay we're telling everybody in
our Network this is what we're charging
and who it's for right and if if what's
his name Tim Tim Fletcher Tim yeah yeah
if you want to give him a cut and he
takes 25% or something as a commission
and he's making money off of it in the
Chinese market great
yeah
but that's that's the plan okay yeah
yeah that sounds really good that's a
good plan I think that's a good start
yes yes totally it's a better no no I
it's a I totally agree yeah all right
yeah let's go thank you Jan thanks aot
let go really appreciate that to watch
me coach another Mastermind member
oneon-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there some people criticize us for doing
what we're doing like you guys are nuts
to start a business at your age why
aren't you enjoying life well I'm
enjoying life now more than I ever have
that's what some people don't get